in 2008 I successfully applied study
physics at Oxford and in this video I
know me showing you how I prepared to
the p80 the p80 or physics aptitude test
is set by Oxford for anyone who wants to
apply for physics engineering material
science for any one of those subjects
combined with another and they do this
to narrow down the number of applicants
to a more manageable level for the rest
this video I'll be talking about the
physics department and how they is the
p80 but it's the same across all the
other departments the physics department
publishes a syllabus of what you can be
assessed on in the p80 and that's
available on their website which I will
link to down there in the description
and it's worth noting that while it does
contain basically AAS maths and physics
there may be subject on it which you are
not familiar with if that's the case
then you are expected to go and learn
those yourself you've got to be an
independent learner one day the physics
department also provide passed papers
and report on each paper and these
papers are the best way to prepare for
the p80 there is worth noting then in
2015 they change the format up until
2015 there were two parts the P 81
multiple-choice section with short
questions and then one part which was
longer answer questions that were worth
more points these have now been
condensed into one paper long section
which contains shorter questions that
are not multiple-choice previous papers
though are an excellent way to prepare
because the question style won't be all
of that different and the best way to
prepare for any exam is to do pass
papers often note that the format of the
paper has evolved over time in some past
papers you were allowed a calculator
while in some other papers including
today's you are not in today's paper
you're not allowed calculators or for me
the sheets so make sure that you have
everything you could possibly need in
your head also make sure that you read
carefully the front page of each pass
paper that you attempt so that you're
doing it with the right equipment
it's also worth reading the reports for
these papers because the physics
department assigns interview places for
applicants based on their performance in
the p80 but the threshold at which you
will be offered an interview changes
year-on-year depending on the
distribution of marks achieved in that
year's paper so the difficulty of the
paper can vary somewhat so when people
ask me as they do an awful lot what mark
I need to get in the p80 in order to get
an interview the answer is as high
possible because there's no way of
knowing so don't aim from our unless
it's 100% a link to pass papers and
their report is also available in the
description the number of past papers
provided however is relatively small so
there are two other things I'd recommend
you do in order to prepare for the p80
firstly have a look at past british
physics Olympiad papers these are really
quite difficult questions that are going
to stretch your lateral thinking skills
that will be an excellent way to prepare
for the p80 and lots of pass papers are
provided online information down there
and secondly also check out past papers
for the UK senior maths challenge this
is a pretty widely taken test that has
really quite difficult maths questions
the first part of which is multiple
choice but the second part has long
answer questions and they are loads of
pass papers available online with
solutions available I will include a
link down there again to both those and
they are an excellent way to prepare for
the more mathematical questions in the
p80 because bear in mind it's not just
physics should be assessed on it's also
your mathematical skills because the
physics course is about leave a mix of
the two I hope that this has been useful
and if you're preparing to the p80 this
year best of luck
make sure that you attend all the
questions and plan your time and do all
the things that are supposed to in exams
but most of Thornton Lee has a bit fun
with it thanks for watching and good
luck this cover stuff makes me really
excited Venus this is why I became a PhD
researcher because science like this is
awesome making incremental improvements
I'm doing battle off secondly cheetah's
will look for students who are
passionate about their subject just
going to demonstrate it in many ways
through clubs through read
are you taking your understanding of the
subject beyond what apart from you from
school the ideal student will be someone
who